i would like to introduce our three
speakers today
so nicolas savage is the founder and
president of tdk ventures
which is the corporate vc arm of tdk
corporation a japan headquartered
electronics manufacturer
tdk ventures invest globally in seed to
be around startups that leverage
fundamental material science to unlock
an attractive and sustainable future of
the world nikolai is an alumnus of iscn
the london business school insead and
the stanford gsb so
lots of different experience and nikola
welcome and thank you for joining us
today
thank you um aparna subramanian is
director of engineering at shopify she
has 17 plus years of experience as a
technology leader building engineering
teams she has successfully built and
launched several products across
multi-cloud and machine learning
platforms she's passionate about
creating and developing inclusive teams
where people feel they belong she holds
a master's degree in computer science
from boston university and a bachelor's
in engineering from anna university in
india and she's based in the san
francisco bay area
thank you for joining us aparna and
welcome and then finally deborah kelly
is an economics and statistics professor
at the university of san diego
she's also involved with the
university's leadership certificate
program she's been chair of multiple
committees and has led a very variety of
strategic efforts within the university
uh and previously in her career uh was a
band branch manager and a software
engineer deborah welcome and thank you
for joining us today
um so uh we're gonna spend the next 45
minutes uh or or uh 40 minutes together
uh and and what we wanted to spend our
webinar today is learn a little bit
about your experience
as managers um navigating this very
complicated transition that we've all
experienced over the last two years from
most of you i'm assuming we're fully in
person
in the office then
likely transition to fully remote uh as
as the pandemic hit us and then are
probably at different places right now
within your organizations as as we start
to transition back so what i wanted to
do is start by asking each of you kind
of to tell us just a little bit about
the team you lead or the organization
that you are a part of and where that
team and organization is in that journey
from
in person to remote and back so aparna
why don't we start with you
yeah sounds good um i'm a director of
engineering at shopify and uh shopify is
a software as a service cloud platform
for e-commerce
we support millions of merchants across
175 different countries
and
my organization decided to go fully
digital by design which is a remote
first culture so
all of us are remote um you know we are
going to be remote all the time and
that's a decision that we've made so
that we can
uh level the playing field uh for for
everybody and uh we also see this as an
opportunity to
future proof uh shopify
and um you know in terms of um where we
are with that journey i think it's
personally it has worked out really well
for me and my teams so we are no longer
restricted to hiring the best talent
just in north america we are able to
hire the best talent across the world
so that's been great and speaking from
my own personal experience as a mother
of two young kids i really love the
flexibility of being able to design my
work around my life and when i talk to
people in my team and you know other
friends they really
appreciate the flexibility and being
more available to their family and kids
and
you know certainly not looking forward
to go back to having to design our lives
around work
wonderful thank you very much
um uh deborah why don't you tell us a
little bit about kind of where where you
are from uh and and where your
university is currently on that journey
well
just as everybody
you know university they went remote and
the thing is i had actually taken some
time off
to
attend a business analytics program
which was this was before the pandemic
and
i
was we had online classes and then we
got together on campus a couple of times
well
i thought it was an amazing experience
we got to know each other really well
for one thing each of the classes
required us to have peer learning
sessions before and kind of review our
homework before we went to class
so when we got in person i was like oh
hi hi yeah i get to see you in person
now but i knew we knew each other
and so when everybody was shutting down
there they're complaining it was like
hey i've been in zoo it's a great
experience so
it was interesting
seeing how people were adapting and
having problems with it when i had had a
great experience but then i do see that
it is
i wasn't being forced to do it all of a
sudden just like you know businesses and
and universities were having to do that
and i do see a lot of
i saw a lot of leaders that didn't have
the leadership skills that they needed
to be in person or online
to be able to lead a group of people
when i know students didn't like being
at home
and
but you need to set up some of the
guidelines for
having
videos on and people to be paying
attention and then also some social
times so that people would get to know
each other so it's been a really
interesting experience to
based on my experiences how people are
handling it
absolutely and so we we've kind of we'll
we'll uh in a few minutes get into some
of the best practices or some of the
things that you have tried um
across your teams or organizations uh
but it sounds like um aparna's
organization shopify has made the
decision to remain remote and there are
many many organizations or quite a few
that have made made similar decisions
deborah it sounds like
in higher education i think
that is the case at stanford as well by
the way certainly there's a push to
start to come back uh onto campus and be
residential to the extent possible but
but there um there are some universities
who have also decided to
to remain more fully virtual nikola what
what about uh tdk ventures what what
have you uh done in this kind of
question of starting to come back and
handling that
transition well so tdk ventures is a
corporate vc
and venture capital is all about people
about entrepreneurs about partners and
it's very much a wide glove
type of
services
and so
you we've been looking at growing our
team and we moved from five people
before the pandemic to now 15 people
and we are trying to be close to the
entrepreneurs close to the innovation
ecosystem so clearly in the us we have
silicon valley
and boston on the east but we also have
japan
france soon india
and
it's it's interesting because apart from
two times where we managed to get
everyone together
two-thirds of the team was
recruited remotely we didn't get the
chance to meet them face-to-face so that
was also a learning here
what's interesting about my journey is
that
10 years ago i was in taiwan and i was
in taiwan for 12 years but five years
out of that when i was in nxp software i
was working from home i was traveling a
lot but five years i was working from
home so i have some appreciation of the
benefits of working from home but also
the value of being close to customers
close to your colleagues
and so
maybe i will end by saying that our
first two investments which was before
pandemic
we actually did everything on zoom so it
was actually already remote and i feel
like we we managed to get
into a setup where we had all the
processes and the tools
already ready for us to be remote
um that's great um
yeah and i think kind of both you and
deborah mentioned that having some
exposure to
zoom and to virtual tools before the
pandemic was really useful in terms of
being able to make that transition uh
more quickly and to be able to still
feel um confident and less disoriented
uh as as this was as this was happening
um
what are some things uh that were
surprising to you as you transition to
zoom in terms of things that you saw not
to zoom or to try and transition to a
remote environment in terms of some
things that you saw uh with your teams
with your staff
uh and and and that that you learned
about your team as part of this process
um aparna would you like to start
yeah yeah happy to um yeah so the one
thing that was really interesting for me
was you know as we decided to hire more
and onboard more people i think
onboarding was a very interesting
aspect
as much as we wanted people to work
asynchronously and rely on
uh you documentation
which is which which works really well
for a lot of you know
everyday interaction meetings decision
making
but handing somebody plenty of
documentation and asking them to onboard
themselves and ramp up doesn't quite
work very well so onboarding is one area
that has been uh
you know which i personally find that it
really benefits from a high-touch
interaction like you know nicolas said
like working with with entrepreneurs
working with customers i think
onboarding is one such area in my
opinion and having an onboarding buddy
who is in a time zone that's closest to
the person who's joining the team and
having that face-to-face interaction of
i mean in a video call of course where
they can virtually uh use a whiteboard
um you know ask a lot of open-ended
questions and just be available for them
and to develop that sense of you know
belonging to the team i think that
really goes a long way so i think that's
that's one area where i would say
not to rely too much on you know just
asynchronous communication and
documentation
we have this system at tdk ventures
where
we want to do a bit like airbnb where
they had this challenging
uh team
mindset of how do we get the onboarding
from a four star experience to a five
star to a six star to seven stars
and
we're getting to a point where now we
have one person who's actually on
boarding
two weeks in advance
and it's not too much but it's just
about saying oh we can't we can't wait
to see you
uh we're planning all these meetings
this is the type of presentation you
might want to read at your leisure if
you want in advance
we're planning
calls for you with various tmt members
maybe three per day on your first week
and we're really challenging ourselves
how do we make it seven star onboarding
and this is even more important when
it's remote because people don't have
the chance to
get into the office shake hands with
everyone and see everyone and then go
for lunch together so you really need to
go
and be more inclusive actually i like
what uh aparna defined in our
introduction which is inclusive team
where they feel like they belong and
where they belong i think is a very
important word and and getting this
seven star on boarding is a way of
feeling in the team even though you're
not going to meet face to face right
away
actually that's the case with even with
students i talked to a student the other
day that said her first year of
being involved or you know being on uh
as part of a university she was in india
and she didn't know anyone
and then now she's come to campus but
then like the other day with spring
break everybody disappeared
and she said ah you know i don't know
who
she doesn't know who to connect to
and so i think that's really important
is when they are when you're bringing
somebody in hey get them connected
somehow make sure that they know some
other people so important
and aparna you spoke about kind of um
data sharing and information sharing
both synchronously and asynchronously
are there any uh and i think you
connected that to hiring but maybe
that's true also um across one of the
questions that
we we saw that came in through the q a
is a question about the fact that
companies might be losing some or
organizations might be losing some
benefits of kind of shared knowledge and
information with this move to virtual
and fully remote
have any of you experienced that
and
if so how are some what are some ways
that um you yourselves as as uh leaders
or employees have tackled that or maybe
from uh
in a more
systemic way that your organization has
addressed data sharing and information
sharing
yeah i think it's really important to
invest in
tooling
content management systems or you know
whatever homegrown systems or commercial
software that people can buy
so that there's complete visibility uh
of information
and um you know that's that's only part
of the
the solution in my opinion because there
is still
definitely tremendous value when having
interactions like virtually or social
interactions for like you know once in a
while
you know getting people together um you
know physically
and things like that so i think it
really is a combination and uh you know
things that helped have helped me
personally is having show and tells
where people come and share
their work uh you know maybe create
videos or actually come and present live
about the work that they've done you
know some project decisions that have
happened over the time uh and stuff like
that so it's it's like you know
asynchronous and documentation alone is
not the solution it really has to be
complemented with
in person interaction social interaction
uh virtual meetings show and tells and
one other tool that's really helpful is
video message you know sometimes i just
create video messages uh that can be
shared with with my team and
organization because it just
communicates a lot more than you know
the the the content and what's written
so uh that's another tool uh that that
is useful
uh nicola would you like to share
and i saw a question also in the q a
from deb cragon about tools and
modification to the processes
i i don't think
we changed our processes and i think we
use the same tools
but what we try to do is to share the
processes more clearly
so all our processes start with being
entrepreneurs first
and so we always start from the
entrepreneurs and what we can deliver
from to them and so everything we do is
along that
perspective
and
and what that means is actually we had
already the right processes we just had
to make sure that everyone knew them and
what to expect
which was good so one thing that i spent
a lot of time on actually was re refine
and communicate very clearly roles and
responsibilities in everyone in the team
and so that actually is probably what
was most important because when you can
meet face to face you can very quickly
agree
who's doing what and why but once you're
remote and you can't talk to everyone at
the same time having much more much more
clarity about who is in charge of what
and who should be included for
information or for decision
that i think mattered much more and that
also i think removed some of the stress
which
i mean the stress increased for everyone
moving to remote and and all your
bearings are gone
and so to have more clarity about roles
and responsibilities i felt like was was
a good step forward
and so that really sounds like again a
focus on sharing of information in
different ways right so even if the
processes existed
there there is a heightened need to be
very transparent about them make sure
that they're shared make sure that
they're clear that the roles and
responsibilities are clear there's less
opportunity to rely on
kind of
information and data sharing that just
happens spontaneously and organically
but really as managers you want to be a
lot more thoughtful about
about how that is shared
and also aparna i heard you say which
medium
we choose to share information sometimes
it's text sometimes it's video sometimes
it's asynchronous sometimes it is
synchronous so
being being a lot more thoughtful about
that um so a related question i had is i
mean i think i think something that
comes up a lot um as as people discuss
remote
work is how do you maintain kind of the
social connectivity and again that's
something that i think managers have to
be a lot more thoughtful about and can't
just rely on you know a coffee uh you
know a conversation next to the water
cooler or the coffee machine and so can
you share a little bit about some things
that you've tried and have worked or
that have not worked uh as you were uh
figuring out some some ways to promote
this social interaction
yeah i can i can try to answer that
first um so i think it's it's really
important to have a process
budgets uh around you know these team
events right i think it really goes a
long way when you know the hr department
or leadership sets aside
a certain budget per quarter per team or
per year per team and have uh resources
you know that may be external vendors or
you know online um you know virtual team
building activities
uh that people can uh managers or
leaders can sign their team up for
uh i think it i think those things
definitely go a long way
and to your earlier point it's like
leveraging all of this but also just
being very intentional about the the
culture and the team right so i think as
as managers one thing as a manager one
thing i've learned is to really step
back and let my team own the decisions
and i can get some of that time back to
really be intentional about the culture
that i want to build in the team to
really be intentional about the the
social interactions and the
opportunities that i can create for them
to build that relationships instead of
you know being the
bottleneck in making decisions for for
my teams
one thing i did
go ahead
no no please go ahead
okay well actually i just want to play
off one thing that she just said is
i think
one thing is when you come to these
meetings to get others to talk and not
just you
being the leader because
then it's just like okay yeah just
yammer on you know whatever um but if
you're okay could you say something
about this or you know ask some
questions to get others involved and
that also gets you to learn about
those other people what they're doing
and that really can be helpful
sometimes with introverts you need to
tell them in advance you're going to
call them on them so that they can maybe
prepare
but also yeah just trying to get more
people in the discussion not to make
them meeting any longer but just to make
sure that we hear from others and not
just the manager
go ahead nicholas
thank you i think
one one thing i was very
conscious is that there's a lot of
temptation to add new things to do new
stuff
and i was confused that this could
actually add even more stress not reduce
stress or improve social connectivity
and that's why i went for this training
because i wanted to hear about best
practices and from from the teachers but
also from the practitioners uh
everyone trying to figure out how to do
things and and i wanted to be very
conscious about not adding new stuff
that could be
counterproductive
and i agree with also aparna about the
intentional and so one of the things
that i did and it comes from my own
management perspective which is
what it is that you woke up in the
morning excited to do
and one of my team member my executive
assistant
she loves people she really wants people
to feel good and so i asked eva
to really spend time
thinking about who to connect during the
week and during the day and make sure
they are okay and to have one person
whose role is actually to make sure that
everyone is okay and no one is burning
out no one is stressed and maybe to
figure out what to do with it and maybe
potentially escalate to me or maybe
find a solution without me in the loop
that i thought was a good way to make
sure that
we had this connecting tissue in the
team that was still happening even
though we were all remote that's one
one thing that i think worked really
well is got that one person waking up in
the morning and thinking how do we make
sure the team and each team member feel
good and and
and and can speak up
yes
yeah so what i love about that is um
basically you're sharing two things one
is you're playing off of people's
strengths and natural kind of uh
competencies so that it's not an
additional chore but it's something that
they really like and i think aparna you
kind of
mentioned something similar and the
other is i think it ties into your
earlier point where you said you want
you clearly defined roles and
responsibilities so you told your you
know staff member this is your role this
is part of your job is to be checking in
with these people and reporting back to
me or looking looking out for the team
so nobody nobody's burning out which i
think is great so creating that kind of
clarity so so that people know what is
what that this is expected of them and
that this is just as important uh job as
maybe i don't know uh doing some uh some
other type of project um because
she has a budget where she can go and
have one-to-one lunch with them she can
send flowers she can do a few things
that are personal touches
that makes you belong and that's why i
really like the word to belong because
for me if you talk about inclusion
it's about feeling like you can belong
you can speak your mind and people will
listen
yes
yeah and i also love the the ritual
right i think it's if we have a ritual
around like okay this is how our team is
going to get together maybe like you
know every quarter we're going to you
know meet for lunch or have a virtual
coffee or something like that you know
then it creates that routine
and you know something for people to
look forward to you know maybe i have
other personal responsibilities i'm not
able to join right now but maybe i'll be
able to join in summer and i can then
plan
to be able to travel or you know be
there uh the next time we meet as a team
so i think there's really something
about that having that ritual
and for example
um you know when i have my staff
meetings uh i mean of course for all the
the virtual meetings we want to have an
agenda and we want to really be prepared
and all of that let's say all of those
are really best practices but then you
know what i found is once in a while to
have a staff meeting uh with my direct
team that has no agenda and just you
know show up in that meeting and ask
how was your week like what was the
highlight or you know low light of your
week uh you know in this this uh you
know this past week and i've noticed
that people open up and people really
like to not have structure sometimes or
have a gender-packed meeting where we're
just discussing like topics or status or
things like that so um i think one thing
is to also be
you know uh understand what works for
your team and and mix things up as
needed
that's great so i have um a question
that came a few questions along similar
lines have to do with um the the work
hours and uh burnout uh related
questions and focus i would say so let
me let me explain what the question is
so there is a question that came in
around how do you
figure out have you defined clear work
hours during the day
to make sure that people were don't work
excessive amount of time and burn out or
have you left this more free form
and a related note is there have you uh
found ways to address either
multitasking where employees are
supposedly in a meeting but actually
they're they're doing something else uh
or that they're just burning out because
of of the excessive amount of meetings
or time on camera etc so this is a
pretty broad question tying in a few
different uh things but feel free to
respond from whichever perspective you
feel you have the most to say about so
uh deborah do you want to uh go first
i'm gonna let uh
one of the other ones go first and then
i'll play into it
okay thank you yeah
so i think it's really important not to
um you know not to make everybody work
in the time zone of the headquarters
right i mean i think we have to get used
to this model where people are working
during their preferred daytime working
hours in their time zone
and i understand the need for some
synchronous communication and some
overlap
but um i think we just have to figure
out a way to make it you know two or
three hours of overlap or whatever the
minimum overlap needed uh for teams to
communicate across time zones because
this is just one of those
long-term unsustainable things to do is
to have you know a
certain team work in a completely
different time zone and i think as
leaders it's very important to model
that and enforce that right and you know
to create opportunities such that
uh you know
an extended amount of overlap is not
necessary
and when i say modeling uh behavior like
if
leaders start attending meetings and you
know early morning or answering emails
after work hours or in the weekends
it
it indirectly creates that you know
expectation or that culture that oh like
okay maybe this is like the work ethic
this is this demonstrates work ethic
like being able to you know extend
oneself and you know cut into you know
devote their personal time but which is
which really is not i mean i think it
really sets a bad example and i think it
you know uh as leaders
they have uh that opportunity to set the
culture for the rest of uh their
organization and the company and they
should
um you know certainly
model that behavior
actually that plays into some of the
things that i've heard for one thing the
research at the be
in the first year of the shutdown was
the fact that people were
more productive
that were working from home
but also that they were answering they
could get up you know maybe eat
breakfast and that kind of thing it's
kind of split their day instead of
normally we drive to work
and then at five o'clock we close the
computer and go home but now some people
were oh okay well it's kind of calm here
in the evening i'll answer some emails
and they were answering emails at nine
or ten o'clock
but the thing is
yes
worry about
burnout that's for sure but also that it
does give people kind of
the chance to spread it out spread out
their work day kind of manage family and
everything else and so that was working
out rather nicely
i was going to give an analogy for me
about overworking and even
burnout
risk which i think is um if you see a
group of boys
who are you're taking a photo of a group
of boys it tends to be boys i think
one of them will stand up you to be a
bit taller
and then another one will try to do the
same and very quickly all the boys try
to stand up to be looking taller and
then everyone is at the same height on
the photo as it would have been if no
one is standing up but everyone is
suffering from trying to stand up taller
and i feel like with everyone moving
remote and saving time on commute you
end up with people working even harder
and then at some point you actually
can't even control it you don't even
realize you're standing up taller for
way too long
and so i think
overworking and burnout risk is true
even in face to face even before the
pandemic
and it's very hard to identify it's even
harder to do remote
and and
i can speak for myself because we just
had last week our second face to face
for all the team
and i think there are two of my team
members
i think are overworking to the point
where they could risk burning out and
one reports directly to me so i i'm
taking steps but this is really really
hard to identify when you just meet in
zoom and the person is smiling and you
can't really tell
so i
i'm looking for for answers to this
actually but but the way i'm looking at
it is this group of people who are
trying to stand taller but actually it
ended up being everyone the same anyway
that's a great analogy and i think um
i think
some some uh
best practices that i've seen um have to
do with really defining hours so i think
aparna you were you were talking about
that a little bit i mean one in terms of
role modeling but also in terms of these
are uh kind of uh work work time that we
are expecting the entire team to
participate in and then uh and then be
much more flexible about other times and
try to disencourage really people from
working to too long hours and i know
nikolai you shared with uh with the
group of us earlier uh some of the
policies that you've developed for
coming back to the office which take the
same approach maybe you want to say a
couple of words about that
where really you've defined some times
that are in person times and then some
some more flex time around that
yeah and maybe i can
first say that last week we did a
inside methodology
review and we identified that in our
team have people like strawbert and half
people are introvert
and
and
what's interesting with that is that you
can expect the extroverts wanting to be
back in the office and to have the
interactions and the introverts wanting
it but maybe not to the same extent
and so the way we've designed designed
our we call it work from the office
policy but it's really a work from home
policy it's just setting the expectation
that we expect some time which is a
monday uh and the
thursdays and we chose the time so it's
actually nice commute time versus when
everyone is commuting so it's i think 11
a.m to
4 p.m where everyone is expected to be
in the office to be building uh some
kind of
camaraderie having the kind of
whiteboard moment where we can
brainstorm and create together
but apart from that as long as a person
has all the right tools at home which
sometimes they don't
especially for our interns they may
still not be able to and therefore it's
better to be in the office but as long
as the person has a room where they can
isolate themselves they can have the
zoom calls or
productive they can work from anywhere
they want and so the idea is to have
this nice combination of
limited time but we're all together
and time where we can work from home and
we can be at our own pace
yeah that's great
um
okay so i'm looking at the clock what i
think we will do is i'll share i wanted
to share a little bit about the program
that brought all of us uh here together
uh so i'll take a couple of minutes to
do that and then i hope we'll have time
for uh one or two more questions so um
the the program that is really
sponsoring this uh panel conversation
today is a program we call leading from
home
managing remote teams and hybrid uh
teams and uh
uh all of the our our uh panelists here
on the webinar today have participated
in that program
and the the program it's been very
interesting we we launched it our center
launched it right uh very closely after
the pandemic started and as we've
delivered multiple cohorts of that
program we've been uh evolving both in
terms of the research that we're
presenting and the things that are being
discovered about remote and hybrid work
as well as the types of challenges that
we see managers and leaders that join
the program are facing
and so here is a brief snapshot of what
the
program covers so this is a live virtual
program it's fully live
in the program we have faculty that are
presenting but just as important i think
we have many opportunities for the
participants and learners
to have a dialogue amongst themselves we
have many breakout rooms and and q a and
conversations and you're seeing a little
bit of that in the session today where a
lot of the knowledge and learning can
happen just by engaging with kind of
motivated and curious and and passionate
peers that are really trying to perfect
their their personal management
practices and you know we have
some prime examples here today on the
call and so here are some of the topics
that we'll be covering so we we have a
session about how to motivate teams and
and uh remote teams uh
as a
a particular example of such uh such
teams we have a session about how to
structure and lead hybrid work and what
it means when organizations uh become
this uh uh in this situation where part
of their staff is in person and part is
remote it's actually quite a challenging
uh situation to solve for and and to do
effectively uh we have a session about
the psychological blind spots of the
13-inch office uh meaning kind of our
our computer screen and what are some
things um psychologically that we need
to be aware of as leaders uh and and
have more focus and attention on uh than
we perhaps needed to in an in-person
environment
um and then uh on the third day of the
program uh we have a session about how
to increase coordination in
organizations that are fully remote
we have a session about how to leverage
virtual teams for innovation and problem
solving so how to make sure that even in
a virtual environment uh we can really
be very innovative and collaborative and
solve problems together
um and uh we close the program with uh
with a conversation with
a professor from mcgill university who
has
done some work on the four-week uh we
work the four-day work week and and what
that looks like which is uh interesting
as we were talking about time and and
how to define time within the work day
in the work week
uh and and then finally some things that
you as leaders may want to subtract uh
like the number of
hours in a day that your teams are in a
meeting and some things that you may
want to enhance um that you want to
build off of like
the example of meaningful belonging and
social time and how to create that so
this is a high level snapshot of the
of the program
uh and i guess uh before we take the
next question i'll see if any of our
panelists if there's anything you would
like to share um that stood out to you
from your experience in the program and
and from uh kind of being a part of it
yeah i can uh answer so i think the
program really helped me to recognize my
own blind spots of uh you know that i
was that i had when leading from home
uh so the example that i shared about
trusting my team more empowering them to
make more decisions and not not being
the bottleneck you know which which does
not mean that i'm not really you know
doing my part in you know my job or
enabling the decision making it just
means that i'm building a high trust
team and how do i do that without being
the bottleneck without without being the
gatekeeper um so that particular thing i
i think the program really helped me
recognize my own blind spots
i think the way i like to think about
the program
and my key takeaway is you have no one
size fits all
and and having maybe a bit provocative
but there's a lot of value from the
teachers from stanford
but actually the value from the
practitioners that were all students and
sharing with each other was really
really helpful so because you're not
talking about any practitioners you're
talking about practitioners who decided
to spend time to learn about the best
practices of leading from home and
hybrid mode and so on and so you have
this group of people who really want to
better
their own understanding and do well for
their team
that's a special group
i agree i like the
the flexibility i like the coffee chats
too that was kind of fun to show up to
that just to get some free conversation
and it was it was really
very interesting but i think it was
just getting leaders to think about new
norms about being flexible
about figuring out who your people are
and
ways to like you were mentioning
ronnie about the
the um
breakout rooms that we did during the
session and you get to know other people
when that's another thing that
workplaces and schools need to do is use
those breakout rooms everybody needs to
turn on their video so we see each other
and we can connect to each other but
just talking to a blank screen
is not a social event and so anyway
those all the little exercises we went
through were amazing i took a for i have
a folder that has all my notes for
everything that we did that week and
it's very thick because i enjoyed the
whole experience and i really learned a
lot so i appreciate it that's why i'm
here to go yeah attend it's worth
it thank you thank you for that
endorsement um and i think we so we only
have one more minute i saw a question in
the chat about whether this webinar is
being recorded yes it is uh the session
was recorded and uh will be uh sending
you automatically a link to to the
recording which you can share with your
friends or anybody who you think might
be interested as well as review yourself
i think let me close with the notes uh
reflection i thought there was an
interesting question that came in that
said oh many of the suggestions that you
are making here um and that are being
discussed can apply to in person
are they really unique to a virtual
environment are they are are they really
just best practices for management um
and i think that's a really really
interesting question um i i think my
personal reaction and maybe that will be
kind of a closing statement from from
each of us around around the table my
personal reaction is yes there are some
things that are unique to a virtual
environment and we cover
many of them in the program but a lot of
what we see is that it takes this
transition to remote basically requires
a renewed effort and a renewed focus
on some basic management skills that we
may have kind of relied on
previously but now we need to hone them
even further and kind of
make sure that we're really conscious
and aware of these any managerial and
leadership decisions that we're making
so that's kind of my personal take
although there certainly are some unique
elements that we also do cover in the
program um any any um other reflections
as a parting thoughts from uh from our
panelists
yeah i agree with uh what you just said
i think a lot of things that were just
you know taken for granted uh in the
past you know we just have to be a bit
more intentional about that in the in
the remote world but yeah i mean yeah in
general yes the best practices are
applied to both in person and remote but
it just needs that extra bit of uh
intentionality
yeah
i saw a lot of questions about tips and
tricks
and and i and this is back to my
conclusion that it's no not one size
fits all
but there's one thing that we
implemented which i think is very useful
for the audience which is around the
hybrid model
and at some point we started to have
hybrid where some people were in the
meeting and some people were remote and
we realized that people were together
start to look at each other and
completely ignore people who are remote
and so what we've done is we've enforced
that even when you meet in the same room
everyone has their own laptop looking at
their webcam and connecting with
everyone else but being much more
inclusive and i thought i was being too
harsh to my team to do that and then i
watched a youtube interview with sequoia
saying that they had the exact same
process and so when we were thinking
about hybrid and inclusion for everyone
including remote i really recommend this
tip of everyone even if you're in the
same meeting room
in the same space
look into your laptop and engage with
everyone even remote
so leveling leveling the playing field
in that way um so so wonderful great to
end with a concrete tip and suggestion i
want to thank all of you again for
joining us today both you the audience
that have spent some time with us uh
today as well as our panelists who have
uh taken some time to share some of
their own reflections and and best
practices uh and i wish you a wonderful
uh rest of your day and good luck
thank you
thank you
you